i've always thought as i've been able to
go and do what i want to do when i want
to do it
i can't i don't have that luxury anymore
dms dating apps i don't have time for
that i don't believe you should kiss a
lot of frogs to find your prince i
believe in grilling them i'm going to be
going on a series of dates to find who
can really wow me
this is thrilling
my name is nohan and i'm here because
you asked me to come does she know that
i'm gay yeah
i'm gonna save your slag i don't know
about dieter no she can ask me anything
nothing exactly
yes i'm [ __ ] ready let's go
hello hi nice to meet you nice to meet
you what's your name no ham cheyenne
nice to meet you are we doing hand shack
why is this guy got a cocktail firstly
uh where's your one i'm not 14 celibate
just yet there do i look forward to in
celibate no
so tell me about yourself no huh what do
you want to know what'd you do for fun
let's start with that what'd you do for
a while well my work is fun
yeah so i'll make videos okay online
wait what kind of online videos
not porn not yet not yet i'll just yeah
would you do porn of course really yeah
have you got a big dick then i think
sarah would you show me i'll show you a
picture if you want it's not like you're
ever gonna get it i'm never gonna get
your dick i don't like girls this is
your first ever female date
i'm my last i won't be doing it but you
might have so much fun with me so you've
never been with a woman i have how was
that for you
traumatic why because i didn't like it
when was that
well how old am i how old do you think i
look 25 i'm 28. oh yeah yeah i was 15.
15 that was your first experience there
is a story behind it you want to hear it
yes we want to hear it i was sleeping
with a guy
who had a girlfriend
stop
when his girlfriend found out she was
like let's get back at him and we'll
sleep together so we'll step together
wait what what what
wait that is like a hundred ways of
toxic so you slept with a guy yeah so
the guy is bisexual yeah or was he like
glossier
so he was by open out by not opening out
but he was boy right so he had a
girlfriend yeah that's like with you
yeah and so you basically preferred him
over here
but she's my best friend now
once and we haven't spoken for about 10
years is wild that is so wild i think
actually that's the wildest thing i've
heard that is just an insight to how
wild my life is yeah would you say
you're like a nice boyfriend
yeah yeah what makes you a nice
boyfriend
[Music]
when i'm actually a boyfriend
i'm very 5-4 that's a big tick i'm still
rating you by the way you're getting a
rating on how you are as a date but even
though listen i've got gay guy made so
i'm going to do the rating for them all
right okay yeah i hope it's a good
writing well i hope you're a good day
we're not even 10 minutes in yeah the
whole time what do you do for work again
well i have two jobs okay so
i still do my my main job what's that
which is um support paper with mental
health i like that um
and then i have my other job which is
our instagram
tic tac making my videos um but now it's
getting a bit more busy with that i'm
probably going to quit my job
just started a business as well oh
brilliant clothing business so with your
mental health work and everything what
leads you to do that my mental health
was really bad i didn't know how to
manage it was it the social media life
that led to this you know mental health
crisis where you're unbalanced like what
is it life experiences yeah being
bullied when you were younger yeah that
and other things that happened to me as
a child traumatic childhood um
lived on my own
from a very young age 16 got into a lot
of toxic relationships with older men
and
dangerous yeah that i feel like as well
like and i mean this with no shade
towards like the lgbt community you know
like i represent with it as well because
to me my sexuality is open yeah yeah
like the older um people that are
grooming younger people
which would be you in your situation
going back to your child's childhood not
saying child but when you're a young
adult trying to discover who you are
coming out as gay
to then have an older man
you know
i don't know yeah
i think but you know i grew up and i got
wise
and i'm dealing with my mental health
better now
so why are you here what are you doing
here i'm here today but i've seen some
of the men that have been on here i mean
what's wrong with them they're not ready
for the mark i would say they just
scream narcissistic to me sociopath yeah
not feeling it
no no you're
do you oh as well
i never used to
did you not no when you spared attracted
black guys what changed especially once
you go black no going back i think
literally that is probably it yeah is
that it i mean it is true what they say
once you go black you never go back and
the reason is because nobody else will
be able to fill up that hole now sir yep
there you go
what would you say is your toxic trait
i'm nitpick i'm a really bad nitpicker
oh you're the worst stopping breeding
nitpickers are the ones you know a
little bit of water on the side i will
turn it
into
yes you can get out of my house i don't
want to see you again so you could just
walk beside yourself have no drama but
you're going to create a whole drama out
of it i'll be like if you don't get out
i'm phoning the police oh my god he has
gone that far he is so dramatic do you
have any red flags
you're not ready to see me off the phone
yes slice down
no i agree with you then really i feel
like why i never put my phone face down
what are you trying to hide from me
why isn't it up the screen side are you
gonna know if someone sent you a message
if it's lifestyle
my white's always been a problem for me
um
[Music]
but then on the other hand you know
you're moaning about your way but then
you should be like cats in your mouth
what the truth was gonna happen
what does um no hun think of women that
sleep about
that's your business sleep before you
want to sleep with yeah tell you where i
was a person
yeah concerned about yeah do you think
because you um are gay
you find it you understand females a bit
more with the whole female liberation
movement and things like that because i
find a lot of men had this misogynistic
one-sided perspective on women not being
able to sleep about whereas
because you're going to sleep with men
you see it from a kind of different
perspective yeah 100 yeah because
i feel like women are
suppressed or have been yeah for a long
time it's generational same with gays
you know trans people all people who
sort of belong in a subgroup yeah that's
not
a white male yeah yeah
yeah have been suppressed so yeah i do
understand in that sense because
it's liberating would you mind if your
partner actually slept with so many
people that might make it great and in
the guy community it's very different
yeah very promiscuous
sleep with everybody different person
every day why is that why is the you
know gay community like very promiscuous
in heterosexual couples
the goals are different aren't there
yeah you meet a woman you get pregnant
you have children together get married
have a house that's how it goes yeah the
process
what's the process being gay
yeah
you make and that's it and
where did the babies come from okay you
can get married now that wasn't always
the why
you weren't able to get married before
things are different now but it will
take time for that to show
so how do you find friendships with
straight men
the big step
the whole thing
it's not good then there's been so many
situations where i've been involved with
straight guys i thought there were
friends that actually have been trying
to move to me okay
no
yeah yeah yeah so how do you actually
deal with like men dealing with you and
stuff i feel like there's been instances
where strike men especially because i'm
online as well some accessible which is
another thing i hate being accessible i
feel like i seek me out
as
an experiment yeah you're gay fetish
yeah
so i do try and keep away now if i can
because
sooner or later will become complicated
where is
the craziest place you've had sex i'm in
a field he's really boring and he feels
the boring aren't they so mad though a
train you've had sex on a train yeah a
train
how
you spend over it's ours is that people
on the train
he had sex on the train that's bad but
he had sex on a train with a complete
stranger that is crazy oh this story
just got madder so you had sex and
trained it wasn't your man or anything
he had sex how how does that come about
i mean the best part about that was i
didn't even pay for the ticket over
back then i was very flamboyantly guy
okay you would know i think i still am
now whatever but you would know
the way that i dress now i don't dress a
bit like a road man now yeah you know
what i mean
so
but back then no that bright pink
you know and uh this guy
he was already on the train
and we got speaking and he was like uh
he had a spliff
and he was like trying to come in the
toilet that's like some spliff
it was like yeah go on there so when the
toilet is like some spliff
and then
you know
he's dick ended up in my mouth and
that's it we go from there don't worry
that's a lot i'm sorry
likely honestly i don't give a [ __ ]
how's your cocktail
oh wow don't [ __ ] drink this [ __ ] i'd
rather drink one
thank you yeah so what is it you said
about me drinking wine i've never said
you personally why anybody just screams
you know my love's over doesn't it
how do you actually deal with like this
overnight fame my videos are always
popping in birmingham so i got used to
it
in birmingham but now it's gone
like nice and wide yeah yeah kind of
gonna put petrol in my car i've got
people taking pictures of me
and then putting them on instagram was
saying look who i seen at the pacific
station
like
can't go down an oil you know in a shop
kind of sit in my car i had an argument
with somebody yesterday because sitting
in my car on my phone having a cigarette
someone comes right through my window oh
my god that's no one that is looking
through the car
i jumped out the car and she when i said
oh my god
do you like the fame
financial is good
the opportunities are good
but then
i've always thought as i've been able to
go and do what i want to do when i want
to do it
i can't i don't have that luxury anymore
i've been able to just get out my car
confidently walk into a shop and know
that nobody's going to trouble me and
i'm i'm not always in the greatest mood
i'm kind of like very great for not
saying that you're not i'm very grateful
for the people that are kind of putting
me where i need to be when i trouble me
and harassment yeah there's a difference
then i tell them to [ __ ] off if someone
just comes to me goes no i love you can
have a picture of course bob come here
let's have a picture you'll leave me
alone then you got what you wanted it's
when you're getting followers when
you're following me around the shop with
a camera
it's the people that don't talk isn't it
yeah it is the people that don't the
stalker people that really make me feel
uncomfortable
and i'm grateful to my fans
who follow me i love them because
without them i wouldn't be where i am
now
but what i want them to understand as
well
well i've done a lot even though they've
it's a nice i've done a lot for them
yeah i've given them content they'll
tell me oh you got me through a lot down
your videos got me through lockdown
well it's all done a lot for you as well
why can't i you can have your boundaries
like yeah have more boundaries have you
um ever been on only fans have you i do
you haven't only hands but there's
nothing on there now oh really he's been
inactive for about two years
nobody subscribed well only fans would
have been for me if somebody had
actually subscribed but nobody did so
yeah the fortunate career so no to only
fans
for now
for now if my career goes ticks up
then yeah i'll try and make as much
money from it as i can what about a
partner having only fans no money it
depends who's who he's uh going to be on
they can't be having any fans and having
all the people how would you feel
actually if you had a partner and they
had owned friends with a female
because technically it's work and
they're actually gay
yeah it's a guy have having sex with a
man money porn industry is that really
how it works
well son no that would make me really
really insecure couldn't do that really
yeah if if my boyfriend wants to be on
any fans he can be on any fans oh we can
now but only with may oh okay our
content you can't go and make contact
with someone else that's a night for me
fetches
what is that black socks
what black socks really is that weird
no you have a black socks finish yeah
what kind of suction
oh
he's [ __ ] it now
black socks and um
harnesses don't harnesses
no what is it a harness is leather
straps that
you put on your body like a harness yeah
okay like a dog harley spot for a big
boy
you wear it or they wear it do i wear it
or wherever
[Music]
what's that you don't know what pop
plays no
what the hell is pup play
what is it puff play
oh next one
all right put play is
someone puts a dog mask on
no that's going too far but you're going
to love it what do you mean it's going
to have you done that now i've been
involved to do it but no obviously
have you gone to sex parties and stuff
yeah what's it like
[ __ ] why is your sex like that wild
again you go to these parties and you're
like
no it's not for me i think
it's quite boring
i wouldn't go that far but you know
probably not 20 at the same time yeah
yeah have you ever lied to
have sex with someone about what like
lied about your age yeah
yeah told somebody that i was leaving i
was moving to spain
but this would be the last time i was
going to say that
it's basically like a believer's
sympathy bang yes sympathy pancake
i mean the worst part about that is i
went to science was the next day and it
was there maybe at the checkout have you
had one night standing that would be it
i've had over a hundred really no
100 one night stand he is active
well yeah i used to be a slag who didn't
did enjoy that i used to enjoy it so
what do you want now would you like
settle down are you looking for fun
i just want to be on my own maybe on
your own yeah sarah
i don't think this is working
if you're going on a date and you're
trying to impress someone why are you
taking them i'm doing something really
adventurous okay we're going
to dragon manor nice we're on tabbers do
you um make them split the bill or do
you pay
i think it depends
who has to
yeah first of all i think we need to get
rid of this
thing though where men always pay the
bill for women
i think yeah because you know it goes
back to what you're saying about being
suppressed well if women want equality
then the need to start paying the bill
acting like
yeah you know they're equals yeah i
think a lot of times
i disagree with that statement i agree
with what you mean but i disagree with
the statement because i kind of feel
like the way you're being treated and
like being oppressed is completely
different to wanting to kind of have a
gentleman caught you but i do agree with
what you're saying because
to be courted yeah i mean like for me if
you're asking on a date and you're a
gentleman not i expect you to pay yeah
but okay you can pay she hit the fan i
need to have my own and i think it's
important that we advocate that as a
society like not city girls style but
just as a woman
hold your own
for me
salary is not an issue
but you need to earn as much as money or
at least be able to pay the bills i
don't want you to pay the bills yeah but
i'd like to know that you could pay them
if i needed you to but i will never need
you to
can i um have a pen please to change the
cards yes yeah i can catch
yes on
no hon i was actually going to be called
yes one you know really
the username was taken
oh really but no hun wasn't so i opted
for lohan and that's how he ended up
here i prefer no anyway yeah
like
yes a no
yeah not being a no
that depends yeah i'm both yeah both
would you prefer it depends on the mood
so i can put these down now cannot yeah
sometimes i want to be like
in control
and then other times i really just want
to be live
me a little bit
that was a bit dramatic wasn't it love
it
yeah yeah yeah
well have you got no one yes because i i
like massages but i don't think i'm
ready to like
go up the hole yet yeah yeah it's nice
yeah it's different isn't it like the
spot is
your hands you've got one in yours as
well in my vagina yeah you can reach it
through the bum
yeah that's that's making me comment
stop being able to clench about 10 years
ago it just thinks what it is
ago
uh no
no
no why because no just no i don't like
it you don't like it no would you like
other people's pictures
yeah
yeah exactly
double standards again have you ever
lost somebody's picture
in the hope that they'll send you a
message i'll slide in i have no shame oh
i will slide them down i wouldn't i've
got my plate sick now so do you think
you don't have to graft as much now to
get sex
yeah but okay no i don't have to but
people didn't want you for the wrong
reasons
yeah
because of who you are do you think that
affects your mental health yeah
yeah no because you don't know who you
can trust you don't know who's legit you
don't know who's
in it for the ride or really for the
bride as well well yeah you know all of
those things
as long as you haven't stepped with
somebody that i've slept with that's the
thing about being gay yeah but i think
but it's hard though isn't it because
they're getting everyone kind of knows
someone that they've slept with that
yeah like you could sleep with someone
who slept with someone who you know who
has also slept with someone and someone
so like you know i've been in a
relationship where i've slept with
somebody
or being in a relationship with somebody
and then like i found out that they've
slept with somebody who i've also slept
with yeah
techy it's a bit grim on it yeah
and they walk into a party together
could you imagine and they're just
they're like
sweet green yeah i wouldn't like that i
just tend to just go about a birmingham
now
say strategic then yeah
no no really not no why not i don't
trust anyone that wouldn't give me their
phone pass code cause i watch porn i
want what point you watch
why don't work on these things
everyone's got fantasies
absolutely no way no i'm not saying that
no i don't know if i'm giving too much
away but someone might want to fulfill
it i've already fulfilled it so what is
it then i can't say it because then
god
think of like
a job
i drive oh my god you're on a madness so
they
no they don't drive them what do we need
oh i think that's their occupation
pilot
no bus driver taxi driver yes have you
done a fake taxi no i'd love to
what could it be
taxi driver it's a taxi driver it's
actually a taxi cab
yeah
taxi driver
sorry i can't afford to pay
he is living out the pornhub fantasy
like he's doing it it's not even a
fantasy he's living it would you date
someone if they'd step with two of your
friends in the past no why not be very
awkward for me there are seven billion
people on the planet i will go and find
somebody else who has not been around
the whole [ __ ] estate then the best
man when though
well i still had it first before it was
used what if they had like a really
crazy ex after them
i've been there i've had that let's see
well how was that
would you stick around now or is it just
like nice yeah i would now i wouldn't
stay around now but i did but now
it would be a no that would be a red
flag okay that would be a red flag
another red flag for me you talking
about your ex
don't give a [ __ ] i don't hear about it
if you're and if you're still talking
you still care red flag bye
i'll literally get up and walk out i
won't stay until the end i'll get up and
go i don't want to hear it i don't give
a [ __ ] about your ex bye but you
remember on a date with me so what if
they wanted to involve other people in
their sex life
i feel like that would end in violence
oh really i really do feel like you're
on smoke literally
somebody would get
do you think you are a good date i think
i have been the best day that you've
ever had and i think i always will be
you'll never have a date like this again
i know ever as women this is the best
date because it's kind of like i feel
like i know i don't owe you sex at the
end of the day yes i like so i feel at
ease i can drink the wine a lot drink as
much one as you like what do you think
of me as a diet oh you're great you're
really great company i love honest
because for me like communication is key
honesty is key and you're funny so you
are taking a lot of boxes are there any
boxes i haven't ticked the fact that you
don't like women
our sex would be awful absolutely
wouldn't even get that far not even
gonna
um the date was so good like it was
such a good day like it revived you made
me laugh ticked all the boxes i think
you were absolutely amazing the best
that i've ever been there oh my god of
course i'm gonna see him again
definitely absolutely i would love to
see sean again
nando's we would go to nando's he said
you're gonna go down though
listen i'm ready i'm booking the table
now ready
i would like to think that i'm gonna get
an eight ideally i would like a ten
because i don't actually think anything
went wrong
and uh most things were pretty much
agreed on so yeah i loved his vibe i
loved the jokes i loved the fact we got
on i loved his honesty the only um
thing roxy didn't take is that he's gay
you know and i need a man that's gonna
you know
give me a bit more than that so i'm
gonna give him an 8.5
i know you're mad because i made it to
the second day and you didn't
you